when 902 Ando star shannen doherty was
ready to open up about her fight against
breast cancer she only sat down with us
and we were astonished to hear that she
had delayed treatment for more than a
year which put her health in jeopardy
obviously and led to a multi-million
dollar legal battle when I'll that
battle is resolved and Shannon finally
has something to celebrate
just hours after news broke that Shannon
settled her fifteen million dollar
lawsuit she had a girls night out at
Nobu Malibu with her best friend and
Marie Kortright a model and was also by
Shannon's side was she shaved her head
the pair stayed until 11:00 p.m.
celebrating not a big payout but the
fact that the nine oh two one oh star
actually felt good enough to eat before
getting her fourth chemo treatment
tomorrow details of the settlement have
not been disclosed but in the original
court papers Shannon claimed her former
business managers were negligent and
habitually blundered tasks which
included paying her health insurance
premiums the company has denied those
claims you're in the shower doing a self
breast exam yes I felt something felt
something went to the doctor I did not
go to the doctor right away my business
managers didn't pay my health insurance
and so I didn't have insurance to cover
me or going to the doctor so he didn't
go to the doctor I waited too long I
wait until I my insurance came back up
and I was eligible and then I went to
the doctor and got diagnosed with cancer
shannon is determined to fight she's
staying active even hitting the tennis
court with her husband Kurt yesterday
because she knows there's a hard road
ahead
you have chemo no Wednesday what's your
Thursday and Friday like you're throwing
up every single second after my first
treatment I lost ten pounds instantly
there's nothing going in my body it's
all going out and as for the future well
the couple still hopes to have children
the chemo sort of stops everything maybe
there's a chance afterwards but you know
being realistic I'm 45 years old so I
have no idea but I think that you know
my husband he's like let's just get you
healthy
let's focus on you
and if once you get healthy and you're
okay he's like if you want to adopt like
let's adopt and you know maybe that's
our path maybe as that is our destiny
certainly a good way to look at it well
Shannon also told us she can't wait to
get back to acting